The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEREMY KEPNER: All right.
We're back.
So I think we just
went over a sort
of a tour of some of the
more complicated analytics
that people can do.
And now, we're going to
show some examples of not
those specific analytics,
but using the Reuters data
set that we had before
some of the analytics
that we can do here.
So again, this is
in the D4M API.
We go into the
Examples directory.
It's Apps.
And now we're going
to deal with tracks.
And this is a data set here.
The data actually,
this Entity.mat
was actually created
in the previous.
And this entity
analysis actually
creates the Entity.mat.
It's the same file.
So we just have over here.
And so let's get started.
And just to remind people,
we do load entity.mat.
You see we have this E here.
That's the data.
It represents, essentially,
almost 10,000 documents
and 3,600 entities in that.
If we do spy E. transpose.
AUDIENCE: Can you move the
bottom of your screen up?
Because we're seeing the
top half of your thing.
JEREMY KEPNER: That better?
AUDIENCE: Much better.
JEREMY KEPNER: OK.
And so there you go.
That is the entire data set.
Again, spy plot, very
useful tool for doing that.
So you can see we have
locations and people
and times in this data set.
We also have
organizations in here.
You can zoom in on
it if you want to.
You can see, the are
the locations, and then
the organizations,
and the people.
Zoom in a little bit
more, you can actually
look at the actual values here.
And you see there's this
common popular location here.
What is that?
Ah, it's the United States.
Yes, the United States
does appear a lot
in Reuters documents
as one would expect.
What do we think
this one is here?
Any guesses?
AUDIENCE: New York.
JEREMY KEPNER: What?
AUDIENCE: Is that New York?
JEREMY KEPNER: Yeah.
Oh, New York.
See, it's already there.
New York.
Yes, we can read.
All right.
Organizations, anything
really popular here?
Maybe this guy, is he popular?
International Red Cross, right?
And people here, we don't
have any really popular people
in this list.
Ahmad Shah Massoud, I have no
idea who that person was back
in 1996.
Anyway, so that's the data.
And you see, by the way, when
every single time you click.
Because when we make
those spy plots,
I have to do some compression
on the strings just
to make it work.
But we actually always
print out onto the screen
the full exact string.
So if I want that string,
you can just then copy it
if you want to
say copy and paste
it or something like that.
Or the full person or something
like that, you can then
copy that and paste that.
You can do something like
that like, E, this guy, yeah.
And there, it's showed.
That's all the documents that
contain this person's name.
And then this shows the
character position, I believe,
that they appeared
in the document.
So again, you have all
kinds of fun with that.
You can do row, that.
That gets us all those rows.
And then we can pass
those rows back in.
And let's say we want
to do starts with,
let's see here, how
about organization?
Everyone correct
my spelling here.
I'm going to type this
wrong, organization slash.
All right, there we go.
AUDIENCE: Starts with.
JEREMY KEPNER: Yeah.
I always get that wrong.
Stars with-- starts with.
See?
There you go.
All right.
So this shows you
all the organizations
that are cited in
the documents that
contained this person's name.
You know?
This is kind of the
spirit of it, right?
I mean, it's like
just, oh, I want that?
I can get that.
Oh, I could then say, oh, all
right, well get me-- you know?
And you could just keep
going and going and going.
If I did r c s of
that, right, it
would never return
those as triple.
So r, those are
all the documents.
C, those are all the columns.
V, there we go.
You get the idea.
So again, very, very powerful
type of syntax there.
All right.
So I'll just give you
a sense of the data set
that we're looking at.
So let's look at the
first example here.
So we're going to do track,
analytic, build, test.
So we're going to build some
tracks out of this data.
So I have these documents.
And they have locations in
them, and people, and times.
So I could say, hey, if
there's a person and a location
and a time in a
document, maybe I could
call that's sort of a track.
So let's do that.
So what do we do here?
So the first thing we do
is we loaded the data.
The string values are
those character positions.
We don't really
care about those.
So we're going to
just get rid of them
and just convert it to a
numeric like we've always
been doing here.
And then I'm going
to say my thing
that I want to track is
going to be anything starting
with person.
So I set that.
And my time thing is going to
be anything starting my time.
And my location thing
is going to be anything
here starting with location.
So I've done the starts
with to get these ranges.
And now, the first
thing I'm going to do
is I want to limit my data to
only rows that have at least
one of all three of those.
So I'm not dealing with I
have a person and a location
and no time or whatever.
So I'm just going
to clean that up.
So basically, I
get all the people.
And I sum that.
I basically sum
across the columns.
So I basically
compress the columns.
And then I sum the rows.
All right.
There we go, sum those.
I get, then, all three.
And then I filter them back out.
And that just reduces this
to the ones that contain
just the ones that have these.
Let's see here.
So now, I want to
collapse these.
I want to create, essentially,
just edges and times.
So I can do that with the call
to type syntax and the val
to call syntax.
And going and bopping back
and forth between that,
I get a set of edges, the edge
list, which is essentially
the document and the time.
And now, I'm going to
combine these back together
into a new associative array,
which essentially still
has the same text label, which
is essentially the document.
But it has columns of time.
And the value is space.
All right.
And then I'm going to do
another one, which is,
again, has a row, which is
the document or the edge.
And it has a column of
space and a value of time.
And now, I can construct
a track from this
through this wonderful
sparse matrix multiply.
So essentially, I transpose Etx.
And then I'm going to
just get the people
and convert those
numeric values.
And then we do this
cat value mul, which
will actually convert that.
These are time tracks.
And these are space tracks.
And again, it's a
little difficult
to explain to you
exactly why this works,
why these matrix multiplies
give us the answer
that we're going for.
Because we're going to have to
sit and think about the actual
matrices.
This is a great example
to go do, and then
explore these various
associative arrays to actually
see why these matrix
multiplies actually give us
the answer that we want.
So in fact, we can
take a look at those.
I just want to look
at Figure 1 here.
So this shows us,
basically, and I
plotted the transpose of
this, the people on the right.
And then these are times.
And so, basically,
for each row here, I
have a listing of times.
And if I click on one of them,
it will give me a location.
OK.
In fact, I think that
number's the number
of times that appears.
So basically, we
have here the person,
Daniel Smith was in a document
with a time stamp of 1996,
November 12.
Oh, that's almost-- yesterday.
And then the location New
York appeared once in that.
Here's another one.
And so this is a track of sorts.
We basically have a
person and a set of times
and a set of tracks.
That's one kind of track.
Another kind of
track here is now
we have person and locations.
So that was the other
matrix multiply that we did.
And so now, we have person
Carole King, location Buffalo,
and on this time.
So those are two different ways
of representing the tracks.
Obviously, these are triples.
But then you can use
either of these matrices
to do additional queries
and other types of things.
All right.
So that just shows you how
using matrix multiplies
and other types
of things you can
construct more sophisticated
graphs or data structures,
in this case tracks, which is a
very interesting type of thing.
Let's move on to the next one.
That's going to be TA2.
So this is a slightly more
sophisticated tract builder.
Again, so when I
read the data in,
i create my three sort
of categories here,
the object, and the
time, and the location,
or the coordinate.
And then I have a
function here called
find tracks, which actually just
goes and creates those tracks
that I essentially did
in the last section.
To be honest with
you, the reason
I did that is because some
of those matrix multiplies
used to be really,
really, really slow.
And so I did a sort
of special function
that took advantage of
certain properties of the data
to make it find these
tracks much faster.
Eventually, I broke down and
just optimized the matrix
multiply.
In the past when I ran that
last query, before it would have
taken like a minute to
actually run the analytic,
which got annoying.
So I optimized it.
But we still have this code.
This code shows all kinds of
little tricks and techniques
for doing things that
are slightly better
and using triples instead
of associate arrays
if you want to do optimization.
So we leave it here.
But the matrix
multiply performance
is now pretty good that these
tricks are less necessary.
So what we want to do here,
we have this track now.
And I want to do a track query.
So I have a person
here, Michael Chang,
another person Javier Sanchez.
Now, Michael Chang was a
tennis player at this time.
Was Javier Sanchez also a
tennis player at this time?
I don't know.
I think there was a
Javier Sanchez that was
a tennis player at that time.
So we just want to look.
We're going to just do,
essentially, here A and just
say give me of this track.
And say give me the listings
for these two people, P1, P2.
And then we use our Display Full
command to sort of make them
in a nice neat tabular format.
And you see here,
basically, here
is Javier Sanchez' listing.
OK.
And here is Michael Chang's.
And you see there's
no overlap here.
We don't ever have them in
the same time or same place.
We can also do things
like track windows.
So we can say I want to
set a time range here
and a location, Australia.
So if we have our
track thing here
and I say, all right,
give me the time range, T,
and then equal to all
locations in Australia,
this shows me all
tracks that essentially
went through this location
in this time window.
And these are the different
folks that they list,
Sanchez, Melissa Russo,
whoever that was,
Michael Chang, and
Michelle Martin.
So those are just an example of
a more sophisticated analytic.
And here, we're
using the fact that
for our associative
arrays, we actually
have defined equals equals.
So this only works,
though, if x is a constant.
So it will check
the value to see
if that value, if it's a string,
if it's equal to that string,
or if it's a numeric
value, if it's
equal to that numeric value.
But it only works
with a constant.
One could argue that maybe
I should make this work
for a list of strings.
But then the MATLAB
syntax doesn't really
work there either.
If I have a matrix equals equal
to a list of-- I don't know.
I don't know if
that really works.
So we try and preserve the
MATLAB syntax where we can.
And again, then we're
just getting the columns.
Again, this thing returns
an associative array.
This equal equals returns
the associative array
of all things that
are equal to that.
And then we can
look at the columns.
All right.
Moving on here, next one's TA3.
So those are fairly
simple track builders.
Let's begin to do
something that's,
I think, kind of-- doing
that track analytic,
one could imagine doing that
with existing techniques that
are out there, existing
tools and stuff like that.
It would be long.
You would write a
lot of code to do it.
But you could do it.
Now, let's do some things
where you go, like, wow,
this is really something
that would just
be prohibitively complicated to
do it using other techniques.
So once again, we load our data.
We convert it to numeric.
We get our object and our
time and our space keys.
We find our tracks.
And then we've built something
called FindTrackGraph.
All right.
And this is actually
not that complicated.
But it is more than,
like, one or two lines.
But what it does, it says,
OK, I have this track.
This track is a sequence of
locations in a particular time
order.
Well, now, I want to
build a graph that's
location by location.
So if a track started
in one location,
and then its next
destination was another,
that will, of course,
create a new graph.
OK.
So I now have a new graph,
which is essentially
220 by 220 locations.
And we can actually
take a look at that.
And that's this graph here.
So this basically
says, you know,
there was a track that
started in Belgium,
and then its next
stop was Albania.
Or here's another one.
It started in Australia
and ended in Colombia.
And obviously, we have
a dense diagonal here,
because by definition--
well, actually
a lot of times, that's
just the way it works.
And so again, here's
Damascus, Florida,
all this type of thing.
So now, we've created a
new graph of these tracks.
Now, we can do something
like a track pattern.
So let's say I just want to
look at the tracks associated
with people associated with
the organization International
Monetary Fund.
So I'm going have
starts with person.
And I'm going to limit my data.
So I'm going to
basically limit it
to data that begins
with the organization.
So now, I'm building
a new graph, G0.
OK.
FindTrackGraph of
just that data set.
So I've basically taken
my A, which is this graph,
and I said, oh, just
go back and find me
the people associated with the
International Monetary Fund.
And now, I can do
things like, all right--
because this track
graph the value
is the number of
times that occurred.
So for instance, if
I say show me now
all edges that occurred
more than twice
and where are the tracks
that were due to people
associate the
International Monetary
Fund were greater than 20% of
all the tracks that occurred.
So basically, I'm
looking for something
that happened more than
twice, in that IMF folks did
more than twice.
And of all the
data, the IMF people
did it a lot of the time.
So we're in a lot of people.
It wasn't just a really,
really popular track.
And so we see here, now we
get Karachi and Afghanistan.
So we had, essentially,
at least two of those.
And all of them were people
associated with the IMF.
Afghanistan and Britain.
Here's Britain and England.
Well, obviously that's a little
bit-- Britain and England
are the same thing, right?
Here's Islamabad,
Islamabad, Moscow, Moscow.
So here just shows you the
kinds of things that you
can do with typing in again.
This is a very sophisticated
type of analytic.
If you were to try and to do
those things using existing
types of things-- if you knew
this was the analytic to do
and someone handed
this to you and said,
go implement it using
another technique,
you definitely could do it.
But discovering the analytic
using existing techniques
would be very, very
time consuming.
And this kind of tool
is very, very easy
for you to explore and get
the analytic just right.
And I would say that
in a certain sense what
D4M is doing here is doing the
same rule that we've always
used MATLAB for in
signal processing.
People use it to play
with their algorithms,
to figure out their algorithms,
to get their algorithms right.
They know this will give
us the right answer.
And then when they
deploy it and actually
make it part of a real
system, sometimes they'll
just take the
MATLAB code and make
it a part of the real system.
But more often than not, the
target system or the target
application will require you to
port it to some other language,
maybe C++, maybe Java,
for deployment reasons.
We still see that
happening today
that, you know, algorithm
development is one thing,
deployment is another thing.
Even if people use
the same language
for doing algorithm
and deployment,
usually deployment
people end up having
to completely rewrite what
the algorithm analysts wrote
anyway.
Because the algorithm
analysts had certain things
they were concerned about.
And the deployment
person will have
completely different issues
that they have to worry about.
But I think D4M
allows you to still do
that same kind of model
on these new types of data
in a very useful
and productive way
to get the productivity
that we want out of that.
All right.
Let's see here.
So finally, one last thing,
a more complicated analytic,
which I call sort of a
multiple hypothesis tracker.
Essentially, what we're doing
here is we're loading the data.
We're going to just
focus on one person here.
And then the locations
are specified by time.
I mean, the time is
specified by the time column.
And location is
specified by location.
And then I'm going to
have this function called
find multiply hypothesis
trackers for Michael Chang
with respect to the data set E.
And what this does is
this says, all right,
in the previous thing, I was
basically just making one pick.
If I had a document and
Michael Chang was in it
and there was multiple
locations and times,
I would just sort of pick one
of those locations and times.
Here, I'm now going to show
you, for Michael Chang,
for each document, all
the locations and times.
So here's, basically,
Africa and time.
And let's see here.
Maybe we can make
this a little smaller.
That would probably help
a bit, a little smaller.
There we go.
You can barely see that.
But you see here, this
basically shows all the times,
all the locations.
And this shows you,
essentially, in theory
the true track could be going
through any one of these.
There isn't a single track
really for Michael Chang.
There's multiple
potential tracks.
And then this complex
value I happened
to store here just because
I'm using complex values,
the first one is the
character distance.
The location is--
so Michael Chang
appears in a particular word
position in the document.
And it tells me that Austria
appears 278 characters
before him and that the time
stamp appears 11 characters
before his name.
And so over here, you
see the time stamp
appears-- this is a
different document,
but with the same time--
in different locations.
So you can then use this data
to actually go back and say,
you know what, I only
to pick the words that
are closest to Michael Chang.
And I want that to actually
be the real track for Michael
Chang.
So that just shows the
more complicated things
that we can do with that.
So with that, that leads us
to the end of the examples.
And if there's any
questions, I'll
be happy to take them
now if there's any.
All right, good.
I'm just showing you some
of the kinds of things
that people can do.
And so there we go.